le 29 juin 1958 ont posé la première
pierre du futur quartier du sanitas
après la deuxième guerre mondiale le
secteur n'était plus qu'un champ de
ruines dévastée par les bombardements
pour remédier à la crise du logement il
fut alors décidé d'y bâtir des hlm à la
place des infrastructures industrielles
et ferroviaires qui serait reconstruite
à saint pierre des corps c'est donc l'un
des temps forts aussi de l'accroissement
de la du secteur ferroviaire de saint
pierre des corps le transfert de l'un
des industries ferroviaires de tour au
profit de saint pierre des corps et le
dégagement des terrains que la sncf va
laisser va léguer à la ville de tours en
1954 pour la construction de ces grands
ensembles le 15 janvier 1959 les
premiers locataires entrer dans leur
appartement
henriette elle est arrivée en avril de
la même année
la première concierge du sanitas est
resté trente trois ans dans cet
appartement elle redit tout le monde s'y
colle on se connaissait pas mais tout le
monde s'entraide et puis après on a eu
les commerçants qui sont arrivés alors
là c'était vraiment l'apothéose
les commerçants juste à côté de nous et
ce qu'on attendait mieux
1 aujourd'hui le sanitas n'est plus un
village mais il garde sa spécificité
voulu dès sa création
celle d'un quartier populaire à deux pas
du centre ville l'opa qui gère quatre
mille logements qui représente neuf à
dix mille habitants
sa piste est forcé d immeubles sont
pourris et tout c'est pas c'est pas
mondiale quoique comme ça fait 28 ans
que je suis là vous savez il ya pire à
moi c'est sûr qu'on m'a toujours un peu
critiqué mais moi je cours je trouve que
dans bon dans l'ensemble si bon les
locataires ne connaissent pas les
problèmes des résidences qui sont situés
à l'écart des à l'écart des villes
derrière un périphérique est très très
loin d'un centre-ville de sanitas est
situé à moins de 10 minutes du centre du
centre de tours les gens bénéficient
toutes les prestations qui sont qui sont
liées au centre-ville soir les commerces
les écoles les lieux de les lieux de de
loisirs comme le palais des sports et
pour nous c'est un véritable avantage
après 50 ans d'existence de sanitas
pense encore à son avenir le futur
tramway desservira le quartier et pour
renforcer le tissu socioprofessionnel la
ville de tours souhaite y favoriser
l'implantation de micro entreprises
on veut aussi que dans ce quartier
balard a trié des petites entreprises
si possible avec des gens du quartier
parce que il ya des possibilités
financières je veux dire pour monter ces
entreprises donc on fait tout pour que
ce quartier vie
e et vieillit bien et vieillissant sur
rajeunissant ce qu est une gageure